- [Voiceover] You probably
recognize these ice cream pellets
as the ice cream of the future.
They're Dippin’ Dots, a summertime staple.
But this confectionery treat
didn't start as, well, ice cream.
It started as cow feed.
Dippin’ Dots were invented in the 80s,
not by an ice cream brand
but by a microbiologist.
Curtis Jones specialized in cryogenics.
In 1987, he was working
for a bio-tech company
in Kentucky, trying to
figure out how to make food
for farm animals more efficient.
His big breakthrough came when
he flash-froze cattle feed
at 350 degrees below zero,
which produced small pellets.
Serendipitously, Curtis
loved making ice cream.
Next thing he knew, he
was using liquid nitrogen
to freeze ice cream at
extremely low temperatures
and ended up with small beads of it.
When eaten, the natural heat
of the mouth melted the beads
and thus, Dippin’ Dots was born.
A year later, he formed the
company out of his parent's
garage in Illinois, but
there was a problem.
Curtis had nowhere to sell the product.
Dippin’ Dots need to be stored
at such a cold temperature
that it made it impossible
for grocery stores
to house the tasty
treat, so he got creative
and marketed his product
to alternate locations.
Now, they're sold at amusement
parks, festivals, zoos,
and other summertime destinations.
But whether or not they
really are the ice cream
of the future, we'll just
have to wait and see.